okay so here are three rules to live by
that will quickly improve your life rule
number one follow the path of most
resistance now this obviously isn't an
absolute rule like you probably have a
lot of resistance towards driving into
oncoming traffic or throwing your laptop
into a lake and that's probably a good
thing but if you have two brain cells to
rub together then you probably know
that's not what i'm talking about here
i'm talking about the internal
resistance you feel when you think about
doing something constructive something
that would move your life forward in
some way or another like writing a cover
letter for a job posting you've been
keeping an eye on or finally cleaning
your hell hole of a garage where you've
been stashing eight months of cardboard
this type of internal resistance that
you feel when you think about taking
care of these things is also the same
type of resistance that feels empowering
to overcome
but paralyzing if we stay under its
thumb but if we can learn to not shy
away from this feeling but instead lean
into it we will find that our life will
rapidly improve because the most
rewarding things in life are hidden
behind discomfort or resistance paywalls
we purchase long lasting order and
success in our lives through temporary
discomfort and if we become aware of
this weird little transaction that seems
to be deeply woven into the fabric of
reality we can use it to our advantage
we can be comfortable with making this
trade as often as possible and one thing
that i've noticed is that as we get
better at willingly leaning into this
discomfort of action after a while we'll
actually start to enjoy the feeling of
resistance it's kind of a weird thing
the discomfort itself becomes exciting
and empowering i think this is because
since resistance is a source of power
after we transcend it then once we go
through this process of transcending it
frequently enough our brain eventually
starts to clue in we'll just link this
feeling of discomfort with empowerment
and we'll get excited to overcome
obstacles and challenges remember this
rule when we overcome resistance we
absorb its power the greater the
resistance the greater the power rule
number two
don't stop doing the things that got you
out of a bad situation kind of a
mouthful but what i mean is that human
beings are pretty hilarious sometimes
it's because most of the time we know
exactly what we need to do to stop
feeling like crap like if we've worked
ourselves into a hole you know we're
playing more video games we're eating
junk food blah blah blah and we're just
not taking care of ourselves we're in
this negative mindset this self-loathing
spiral eventually this goes on for a
long enough period of time that we
eventually snap we say you know what i'm
tired of living my life like a piece of
crap i'm gonna change things up so we
bounce back we start eating better we
start going to the gym we start getting
our work done on time we start showering
in the morning and dressing into
something half decent and as we do this
we start to feel better and better we
start to feel more confident we start to
feel more energized and better about
ourselves but the weird thing is
something usually happens since we no
longer have that negative incentive to
work ourselves out of the hole we kind
of forget why we were taking care of
ourselves to begin with so we start to
slip we cut corners we skip the gym one
day that turns into two days which turns
into a week into a month and we
eventually slip and slide down the
slippery and slidey slope back into the
hole from whence we came but have you
ever considered what your life might
look like if you didn't stop doing the
things that got you out of a bad
situation because in reality there's no
secret to success success isn't built by
doing you know lavish extraordinary
things like banging out an entire book
overnight 200 brilliant pages of
literature and it's not by going to the
gym harder than everyone else that one
time you're motivated to go to the gym
you know you work out so hard that one
day you just explode into this meat
mountain no it's ridiculous success is
built by doing the same things that got
us out of our rut but just continuing to
do those same things every single day
over a long period of time the key is to
just do these things long enough that
they get locked in as habits habits
meaning that they're easier to do than
not to do because that's what happens
when you engage with these things for
long enough they'll eventually just
become a part of who you are and they'll
be easier to do than not to do and if
this sounds kind of miserable to you
just know that it doesn't have to be
such a grind because as i've mentioned
previously eventually doing these
constructive things feels really good on
a long enough timeline you'll begin to
look forward to these things not as a
means to an end but because of the way
they make you feel so start small try to
implement one simple habit that you
actually think you're going to stick to
lock it in for 30 days or however long
it takes until you feel like it's really
sticking and then add a new habit and
keep on doing that until you're in a
place where you feel satisfied with your
daily life and the activities that you
do on a daily basis you know that's
different for everybody but use your
judgment okay rule number three record
everything so life can be pretty
turbulent some days life really just
deals you a hand and maybe
something truly devastating happens to
you and it rocks your world and you have
no idea what to do and other times you
have an amazing day you know you feel
euphoric on top of the world you think
to yourself holy smokes why don't i feel
like this more often instead of
remaining completely oblivious as to why
you feel good or bad why not start
writing stuff down and recording your
thoughts and feelings on a day-to-day
basis because when you do this patterns
start to emerge you start to realize
that there's an intimate relationship
between your repeated behaviors and the
way that they make you feel so i truly
believe one of the best bang for buck
habits you can start implementing is
just recording your thoughts either as a
voice memo or as a written document on a
piece of paper or a notebook because
once we start verbalizing or writing
things down taking our thoughts out of
the weird cobweb ridden nest in our head
and manifesting them into the real world
as woo-woo as that sounds it's easier to
see our thoughts for what they are and
once our thoughts and behaviors are
actually recorded in an objective way
then it becomes really difficult to keep
making the same mistakes you'll start to
eventually clue in that oh when i do
this i feel like that when i think these
types of thoughts it makes me feel like
this and hypothetically yeah i think you
can come to these conclusions without
writing these things down but why make
this process of growing as a person any
slower than it needs to be and no matter
whether you're recording your thoughts
and feelings from a good day or a bad
day all information is good information
use this information to your benefit and
your life will dramatically improve so
that's pretty much it these three rules
have really helped me in my life and i
really hope they help you as well i just
want to give a big thank you to
skillshare for sponsoring this video for
those of you who don't know skillshare
is an online learning community with
thousands of classes covering dozens of
topics i'm always blown away by just how
many inspiring and insightful filmmaking
classes there are on there that really
helped me bring my videos to the next
level and maybe you're not into
filmmaking maybe you're into photography
or cooking or coding or learning to play
the piano you know no matter what you're
into or what you want to learn there's
probably a class for it on skillshare
and i always find that classes on
skillshare are extremely practical and
that's because skillshare classes are
designed for real life it's super easy
to take whatever you're learning on
skillshare and apply it directly to your
real-life pursuits and skillshare is
doing this awesome thing where the first
1000 of you who click my link in the
description below we'll get a one month
free trial of skillshare premium so make
sure you take advantage of that link
learn something new explore your
creativity and as usual have a great
time so if you like this video make sure
you actually hit the like button because
when you hit the like button the
algorithm says
wow this video must be pretty good let's
recommend it to more people and that
could potentially help somebody out if
they're not having such a good time in
life and you know my video helps them
get out of a bad situation and let's not
lie it helps me out too it helps me do
what i do and continue to make youtube
videos and i like making these it's fun
other than that thank you so much for
watching make sure to check out the
second channel i've been a little bit
inactive on there recently but exciting
things are coming in september uh so
make sure that you don't miss that other
than that
thank you so much for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video exactly
do you understand me cover wire i
understand you are you